and finally new rule just because you
have a stone-faced
doesn't mean you belong on Mount
Rushmore for over two years America has
had a crazy person in the White House
and for over two years the Democrats
have done fuck-all about it because they
were waiting for Muller we all sat
around waiting for prosecutor Jesus to
turn in his big report and he came back
with ask someone else
we need a Superman and we got Clark Kent
Trump calls the mullah report the crazy
mullah reported in a ways right because
it's over 400 pages detailing
terrible crimes by a corrupt president
yet Muller does not prosecute if dusty
Eskie had written the report it would be
called crime and no punishment lawless
report is full of butts Don jr. met with
the Russians but mana fort gave internal
polling data to a Russian but Trump
obstructed justice every day but Robert
Muller he loves big butts and he cannot
live
[Applause]
Preet Bharara was on real-time the week
that marked the bar summary came out and
I had one burning question could a
different prosecutor have reached a
completely different conclusion and he
said yeah that's all I need to know I
get it mothers a Boy Scout a straight
arrow he played it by the book but you
may have noticed for the past three
years were kind of been off-book and
greatness sometimes means not doing
everything by the book
Thomas Jefferson made the Louisiana
Purchase in 1803 doubling the size of
the United States without any authority
to do so but history called his name and
it said take the shot MAV
that's what Spielberg's movie Lincoln is
about even after the Emancipation
Proclamation black people were not free
that required a constitutional amendment
initiated in Congress and to make that
happen
while he had a window to make it happen
Lincoln lied bribed freed prisoners even
fast-tracked an entire new state into
the Union
none of which Muller would have had to
do all he had to do is what people in
the justice system do every day used the
law to come to justice not be so
restricted by technicalities that the
bad guys win
[Applause]
[Music]
this is why Clint Eastwood never made a
movie called clean Harry sometimes it
comes down to you the Attorney General
is corrupt the Congress is dysfunctional
what good is leaving a roadmap for
impeachment if you know a tribal party
before country Republican Senate will
never remove the president Bob your
trail of breadcrumbs isn't good enough
we're not that smart anymore America is
an aging shortstop you have to hit it
right at us
to me this report is summed up in the
words Donald Trump jr. declined to be
voluntarily interviewed so make him was
he too busy you couldn't work around his
tweeting schedule a new tough guy
couldn't get the president's taxes you
didn't follow the money you didn't
interview Trump
we're told because he couldn't possibly
testify under oath without perjuring
himself and that's our problem it's one
fellas punt after another thank you
Rudy Giuliani said this week there's
nothing wrong with taking information
from Russians that's where we are now I
lay that on Muller from now on you can
meet with foreign governments invite
them to hack your opponents break
campaign finance laws as long as it's by
reason of duh unpleasing to Doug to know
what IRA doing for a guy you didn't want
to break precedent by indicted a
president Louis sure created a lot of
new precedents because that's what law
is new precedents it's always evolving
you can't indict a sitting president
it's not in the Constitution it's not
even a law it's a guideline like
drinking white wine with fish or not
[ __ ] your cousin
[Applause]
it's a [ __ ] memo in Watergate the
special prosecutor Jaworski faced a very
similar guideline but he understood the
big picture and his role in history and
he sued a sitting president anyway
Muller could have done that and the
headline the next day would have been
Muller breaks with precedent in Deitz
Trump and then that would be our new
reality
and it would have been a better reality
because now Trump goes into the election
as a vindicated martyr and hell hath no
fury like a whiny little [ __ ] scorned
maybe we should have brought back Ken
Starr his prosecutor at least he knew
how to go after a dick in the Oval
Office
you